investigators in a deadly warehouse
shooting in Maryland are still looking
for a motive today police say that snow
Chuck Mosley killed three co-workers at
a Rite Aid distribution center and then
she shot and killed herself three others
were wounded in yesterday's shooting
Molla langa is at the warehouse in
Aberdeen Maryland with more on this
story Mullah good morning oh good
morning this was the third mass shooting
in the u.s. in two days Mosley was a
temporary employee here at the
distribution center only on the job for
a few weeks the witnesses say she got
into an argument with another employee
right before her rampage just after 9:00
a.m. police responded to a shooting at
the Rite Aid distribution center in
Aberdeen Maryland about 30 miles
northeast of Baltimore terrified
employees frantically piled out of the
building as law enforcement officers
rushed in one employee says he ran to a
nearby business for cover after he was
shot in the leg outside and then moved
into the front of the building Harford
County Sheriff Jeffrey Gayler says snow
- Mosley killed three people and wounded
three others he says the 26-year old
then shot herself and died at a hospital
police searched multiple addresses
belonging to Mosley including this
apartment complex we do not have a
motive yet so everything is being
explored
authorities believe Mosley used a nine
millimeter handgun in the shooting
according to a recent study by the FBI
it's rare for a woman to commit a mass
shooting in 63 shootings between 2000
and 2013 94 percent of the shooters were
male she didn't have a particular target
she was just she crystal Watson's
husband works at the distribution center
and knew the suspect it's not a mean
person he was like she just always
really quiet kind of fine and keep said
he would have never gone never would
have thought this is the third mass
shooting in Harford County in the past
two years something too familiar for
local officials we unfortunately have
perfected this and I hope that we don't
have to do this again in the next 10
years or ever
the ATF and FBI are both on site here
helping local law enforcement with their
investigation and investigators say
terrorism was unlikely though they have
not completely ruled it out the gun that
was purchased by Mosley and used in this
shooting was purchased legally the
wounded victims are recovering at a
hospital and Anthony they are said they
are expected to survive
olenka thanks mola